There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of the most-hyped
products from May to test for ourselves.
Donni Davy, the head makeup
artist of "Euphoria,"
just came out with her own
makeup line, Half Magic,
and I bought a bunch of
products to test out.
First up, we have these
Chromaddiction matte eye paints.
They have a lot of pigment
and were really easy to layer and blend.
They don't dry down too fast,
and you can use them as eyeliner,
which is what I did.
They have this reusable
wing guide, which was OK.
I feel like it was a little too flimsy,
so I didn't get that
great of a wing with this.
This Glitterpill was so pretty,
and the applicator made it so easy to use.
Plus, you don't have
to use a glitter base.
It just dries down and stays put.
The Light Trap glow powders
definitely do give you a nice glow,
and you can use them anywhere on the face.
Like, I put this purple one on my eyes,
and it looked so cool.
Of course, I also had
to get these iridescent
face gems, which are self-adhering,
so you don't need any
glue for the first use.
You will need glue if you reuse them.
These are so easy to apply
and add such a cute sparkle.
The last product I got was
the Magic Brownie Liptrik Kit.
It has a darker and lighter lip liner,
so you can customize the lipstick.
The lip liner is very smooth and creamy,
and this lipstick is super
comfortable on the lips.
This brand as a whole really inspires you
to play with your makeup, which I love,
and I really liked the
products that I tried.
I'm excited to see what
they come out with next.
Danessa Myricks Beauty just released
this Skin Blurring Balm Powder.
I got the universal shade,
which is translucent,
and I also got the shade 4.
So, you can use this as a primer,
concealer and contour, a foundation,
or it can be used to set your foundation.
I first tried the
universal one as a primer
under my go-to foundation.
The texture is kind of strange.
It blends in easily like a balm would,
but it dries down to, like,
a soft-matte powder finish.
It really does blur a
lot of imperfections.
My foundation went over this so smoothly,
and it did make it slightly more matte
than it usually looks, but I didn't mind.
Then I tried the tinted
shade just as a foundation.
It did take me a while to blend out,
but once I did, I really liked the finish.
This is actually more full
coverage than I was expecting.
I feel like it covered a lot!
I did end up wearing
this for the entire day,
and I noticed that I was much less oily
at the end of the day than usual.
It does have a bit of a learning curve,
but once you figure out
how to make this work
for your skin, it's a really cool product.
I don't know why it's taken me this long
to try the About-Face
Matte Fluid Eye Paints,
but I'm finally doing it.
These are liquid eye colors that come in
full-coverage mattes or sheer shades.
Don't be scared by that orange swatch.
That one is a sheer shade.
The pigment in these is incredible.
They're super easy to
apply and to blend out.
You can build up the color if you want,
and it still feels lightweight.
Plus, I'm in love with this packaging.
These are amazing, and I need more colors.
The Espressoh Glassy blush is one of those
pH-reactive products.
It goes from clear to a
pink tint on the skin.
I first tried it over my foundation,
and it started to break down
the product I already had on.
It was pilling so much.
So we were off to a bad start.
I tried it out on my bare skin,
and it worked a lot better.
It's cute and a fun idea,
but I'm not blown away by this.
I would rather just get a blush
that works on skin and over makeup.
This is the Bdellium large
rounded double dome blender,
and it looks like a little mouth.
It's basically like two brushes in one.
It's supposed to blend
in product really fast
and give you an airbrushed finish.
You can use it with any liquid,
cream, or powder product,
so I decided I would do a full face
with just this brush.
I was immediately blown
away by how quickly
and seamlessly this
blended in the product.
Plus, this was, like, the
softest brush I've ever felt.
You're supposed to do these
back-and-forth motions,
and I thought it would look so streaky,
but it just looked really
smooth and well blended.
Because of the size, it is
a little difficult to use
for the more precise
products, like concealer,
but they do sell smaller
sizes of this brush.
I loved it.
This is the Saie Hydrabeam brightening
and hydrating under-eye concealer.
It has a radiant finish,
which had me a little worried.
I don't really think "radiant"
when I'm picking out a concealer.
The coverage is light, a
little too light for my taste.
I'm a medium- to full-coverage girl
when it comes to concealer,
but the finish is pretty and skin-like.
It also looked good when
I set it with powder,
but I absolutely hate
the applicator on this.
In my opinion, it's too short.
It is so stiff, and it
doesn't do a great job
of picking up and spreading
the product around.
Other than that, this is a
very nice everyday concealer.
These are the Tarte
Maracuja Juicy Lip Plumps,
and they're supposed to give
you a tingle-free plumping.
They actually are so juicy.
Look at how shiny that is.
My first reaction to these was that
they are incredibly fragile.
Like, you want to be careful with how much
pressure you're using,
because it will break.
So I didn't love that.
But these feel so good on the lips.
Like, I could not stop
rubbing them together.
It's so comfortable and hydrating.
The plumping was actually
tingle-free for me.
It just felt minty, like I
rubbed toothpaste on my lips.
The plumping effect is subtle,
but I still really liked these.